before the game we unveil the Eastern Conference
Allstar so far one player from each team obviously
Star studed as you would expect maybe one
surprise Bo Jenner broken jaw right now due
to be back around the 19th of January you know
you had fan Tilly on that team Mar chenko having
a good year but it is Jenner for now but again
you the fan can vote the rest of the teams in
so here's the Western Conference Allstar so far
one for team breaking news yeah breaking news
McDavid in an upset okay he made it that's good
news he's been cooking a late as if you haven't
noticed and Conor Bard will be there in Toronto
well he has definitely uh been the talk of the
League this year coming in as a rookie and not
disappointing anybody exceeding expectations
in my opinion and the skill set are just the
skills we haven't we don't know that yet how
about this guy just an absolute horse I mean
you want to talk about MVP candidates he's got
to be in that conversation absolutely even with
the team that he's with hasn't W one yet listen
when they've been going through their droughts
he's still stayed his level of play has never
changed how has this guy's life turned around
from the last few years in Buffalo will I play
again will I get surgery how about a cop and
now an Allstar and just keeps getting better
for Jack and you know he just seemed to take all
the relieve all the tension and anxiety that he's
had coming into the league and injuries and what
not he found himself a great home in Vegas fit
into the team seamlessly and well here we go
the rest I love this how we unveil the rest of
the squad I love how about Frank P Toronto what
a deal for Frankie to go to Toronto listen I I
don't mind Frank but I want to see Trevor zers
in the allstar I got to there's one guy I want
to see him maybe Anaheim gets two the fans can
he's a popular player had a great season though
lhol will be traded Robert Thomas is the blues
fella York Strand for Seattle AER talet heluk
those are three Americans or is eluk Canadian
lot ofal American three Americans so far in net